the world is entering a new geopolitical
era for the first time since the Cold
War the United States has to contend
with a credible rival China there's no
concern tonight about China's military
capabilities amid a report the country
recently tested a nuclear-capable
Hypersonic missile and it's understood
that U.S intelligence had no idea that
China had moved this far ahead but let's
be real it's industrial Warfare China
didn't just speed up the United States
military stopped innovating I think it
was the Secretary of Defense at the time
said we are going to go through a period
of consolidation budgets will not be
growing and left the world in a
precarious situation there are still
people in the world who want to use
large-scale violence to achieve their
aims but not for long Silicon Valley has
always been the Global Hub of innovation
but the real action is actually
happening 400 miles south in a
non-descript Costa Mesa Industrial
District
the tech coming out of this tiny
Warehouse will impact the food you can
buy or how much gas you can put in your
car and if they're successful they may
prevent the USA from going to war and
the craziest part is that it was all
started by the guy who founded Oculus VR
this is the story of anderol
like any great startup story we need to
understand the founders behind the
business first I was super fortunate to
go inside of anderol they introduced me
to the entire team and I got hours of
interview footage that I want to share
with you today
so you're probably asking how does a guy
known for gaming headsets become the
founder of America's Next Big defense
contractor
my name is Palmer lucky I used to be an
outdoor kid and then I discovered
computers and I became an indoor kid
I really like working with all kinds of
various hardware systems SO gas lasers
solid state lasers Optics displays when
I was 15. I was a PC Gamer and so I'd
been building my own gaming rigs I was
into modifying game consoles I ran a
game console modification Forum called
mod retro so I had like an eight monitor
PC gaming setup and I started to think
for myself okay well what's the next
step it's not just higher resolution it
was clearly VR
all of the headsets that I had tried I
said these aren't nearly what I'm trying
to do so I decided I was going to have
to try and create something myself so I
picked up a lot of old gear from a
variety of places that I started to
reverse engineer and I learned a lot
from those I learned mostly what not to
do it took years before I finally made
something where I said okay I actually
can make something that can pull this
off it's not just a cool hobby a thought
experiment breaking news today Facebook
just announced it will acquire Oculus VR
creator of the much hyped virtual
reality Tech Oculus Rift there are a lot
of reasons to believe that the next
major Computing platform is going to be
connected to more directly to to Vision
the explicit deal is that we would be
run as an independent company that we
were in control that it was our vision
and the reason that it could be our
vision is because our Visions were
aligned it wasn't until later that they
really started to centralize control not
just of oculus but of all of their
acquisitions
yeah
so Palmer was the the founder the
Visionary of oculus he was 19 years old
he was 21 when they sold it he's a
brilliant charismatic guy he was the
face of the industry and so he also
happened to be a trump supporter what
happened was in September of 2016 Palmer
donated a little bit less than ten
thousand dollars to an organization
called Nimble America on September 22nd
uh 2016 The Daily Beast comes out with
an article about Palmer and the headline
is Facebook billionaire secretly funding
Trump's meme machine the latest tech
revolving door Facebook says the
controversial co-founder of oculus is
out Palmer apologized in a post right
before the Oculus connect conference
this is oculus's big developer
conference that they hold at the time in
March 2017 uh Facebook provided no
explanation for his firing why was
Palmer lucky fired
that is a specific Personnel matter that
seems like it would be inappropriate you
just made a specific representation that
you didn't make decisions based on
political views well I can commit that
it was not because of a political view
one of the reasons that people have
tried to turn me into a partisan figure
is because it's really good for clicks
the reality is I spend maybe I don't
know one percent of my time on politics
I said 99 on Tech
the craziest thing about the Facebook
Saga is that after the fact Palmer
eventually got a 100 million dollar
settlement because Facebook had violated
California law by punishing him for
political activity most people who made
that kind of money would just sail off
into the sunset but not Palmer he can't
help but look for the next big idea
and when I left Oculus it was more
apparent than ever that the traditional
defense contractors who were really good
at building things like better fighter
jets bigger submarines bigger aircraft
carriers were not well equipped to build
the technology that was going to matter
for the future of warfare and I realized
there was this fiction taking holds in
the minds of people even smart people
that we lived at the end of history
people called it that that there was
never going to be any more large-scale
conflict that economic entanglements
precluded the idea of large-scale
warfare and it was also abundantly clear
the technologies that were equipped with
the technology and the tools and the
talent to make a difference in this
space were largely refusing to work with
the defense sector they were refusing to
work on defense technology that is
really the reason that I started
thinking about what a Next Generation
defense company would look like what
would it look like to build a company
they could take those bright people out
of the advertising industry out of the
search engine optimization industry out
of the augmented reality mustache Emoji
industry and put them to work on things
that were more important I wanted to
start a company where really smart
people could work on National Security
problems and work on the technology that
is going to keep our values safe
around this time Palmer went to the
founders fund CEO Summit in Canada and
he meets Trey Stevens there and Trey had
worked for the government and at
palantir and was investing at Founders
fund trying to find the next great
defense tech company at this point it
was clear that they needed to start a
company instead of just trying to find
another company to invest in it was a
pretty small group of people at the
beginning you had me you had Trey
Stevens who was working at Founders fund
when I first engaged with him about
starting a defense company he told me
that he was building a Ramjet in his
swimming pool in Woodside how you had
Brian chimp who's director of
engineering at palantir the other really
hard part with being a defense business
is in in particular being a defense
Prime is the breath the skill sets you
need to have is massive you had Matt
Grimm who was also from palantir we had
no ideas we'd have a name one of the
other co-founders Joe Chen who was a
product lead and Hardware lead at Oculus
he's also a former paratrooper so you
really cared about the military Mission
we originally had this lunch at Palmer's
house and we pulled together like all of
our smartest friends that we have worked
with before and me Palmer and Grimm gave
a pitch like a very very bad pitch deck
in Google slides and we were like this
is like we're gonna build a Next
Generation defense Prime and we're gonna
like try to convince you over the next
90 minutes that this is the right thing
to do and we went to the pitch I
answered a bunch of questions and then
we were like you know we need mechanical
engineers we need electrical engineers
we need airframe experts with like the
10 skill sets you need on that on
propulsion and avionics and controls and
experts on electronic warfare you know
jamming and you know Communications
waveforms and antennas and all this
stuff basically everyone in that
original lunch ended up joining the
company we all sat around a table and
decided uh what's this company going to
be called what is our logo going to look
like we literally drew it up on the
Whiteboard on the first day and the one
we drew on the Whiteboard is still our
logo we sat down on the first day and
said okay like we've we're going to
start this next Generation defense Prime
what are we going to build
even though big projects like the F-35
were getting tons of attention for going
way over budget the andoral team didn't
want to build Exquisite systems this was
for two main reasons first off even
though they had a great team and access
to venture capital there was no way they
could raise enough money to go build
something like a new fighter jet but the
second reason was arguably more
important across the battlefield more
and more systems needed to become
tradable meaning they could sustain
losses while maintaining combat power
and we actually started with two things
one was a firefighting tank called the
Sentry tank it was a tracked vehicle
that could carry several tons of
firefighting foam or water hit team with
overhead drones looking down at fires
that were ongoing so that you could know
where the heat was best you know
coordinate how to respond anderol had
gotten the famous mythbuster Jamie
heinemann to sign on to help build it
the firefighting tank had no customer
was like something that we really
thought was important that we wanted to
work on and it didn't go anywhere but I
think primarily for political reasons
which turned then into business reasons
to be clear the vehicle like it worked
like we built it we actually have two of
them sitting in a warehouse this was a
tough moment for the annual team they
clearly wanted to help firefighters stay
safe and be more effective but actually
getting a contract across the Finish
Line was simply too difficult
in March of 2018 the federal government
started working on a funding bill that
would address border security Trump
wouldn't get his physical wall but there
was going to be 641 million dollars in
funding for alternative approaches a
series of sensor Towers could
effectively act as a virtual border wall
and identify anyone who is trespassing
on American property so the annual team
focused on the sensor Tower project
basically a tower that scans for miles
around 360 degrees and identifies all
the drones Vehicles animals whether you
like the politics of it or not like
there is going to be a ton of money
spent on border security you know it's
just very practical we got to do this
thing no one's going to let us go to the
you know the Super Bowl yet we got to go
win in the minor leagues until the user
understands what they have it's very
difficult to generate support and so you
need enough Towers deployed along the
border for agents to have used the
towers to appreciate the value they
provide we made huge Investments on our
own dime to get it there we had very a
little margin for error so I can't tell
you the number of times I thought we
were going to fold the company like I
was just like we're betting everything
on this and if we don't win we're
screwed
just a few months later they were ready
to demo the product unfortunately it was
a smashing success the border patrol
agents could clearly see how these
unmanned Towers could dramatically
increase their effectiveness without
requiring more agents it's not an
accident that our first important
Partners were border patrol and Socom
these are people who are on the front
lines that's what they have in common
they are actually out there they have a
real need it's not hypothetical but
working on border security created new
problems for the company all of a sudden
they were being framed as some sort of
extension of the Trump Administration
lots of negative news articles tried to
make it sound like Andrew was doing
something controversial endural
Industries is trying to sell the
government on using virtual reality as a
solution to stopping people from
illegally crossing the border these are
the people who are extremely close to
the specifics of these Technologies who
know full well how brittle these systems
can be Palmer lucky and his his
political views are antithetical when we
got started was basically like trumpy
fascists because it's you know good
ragey clickbaity type stuff Trump was
obviously the most vocal about border
security but Biden also took the issue
seriously Brian came in saying that he
was not going to support border wall but
he would support border technology the
reality is everyone agrees that we need
to know what's coming across the U.S
border they're particularly disagree on
immigration policy but immigration
policy is separate from awareness of
what's coming across the border and
Andrew makes technology that we use to
track drug trafficking human trafficking
arms and cash smuggling in both
directions going across the border
political power can change hands very
quickly in America so it was important
that anderol didn't get pigeonholed into
only being able to do business with one
party fortunately their core team was
already equipped to handle this problem
the way it really works is so Brian's
Democrat and he does fundraise for
Democrats I'm holding I do fundraisers
for Republicans you know we have our
different politics but we agree on what
we're doing here at anderol and so it's
really nice where he can talk to all the
Democrats and it's like you know hey I'm
I'm the big guy in
and they're they're like oh I'm tired of
the CEO that's great and then for the
Republicans I'm talking to the founder
Palmer trust Brian and Brian trusts
Palmer to be on TV and do all the stuff
he does well and be the expert on the
hardware but Palmer trust Brian to run
the company and be the CEO that's not an
easy thing if you're the founder the
sensor Tower project was a good stepping
stone for them but it wasn't really the
big leagues yet remember that Andrew was
started with the idea of preparing the
USA for major geopolitical conflict and
the century Tower alone wasn't going to
change the landscape of that so they
needed to go a lot bigger selling to the
government is extremely difficult
budgets are often parceled out for
political reasons and contracts take
years to iron out the anderol founding
team knew that there had to be a better
way they wanted to flip this model on
its head but there's a problem
[Music]
in defense Tech there's something called
the valley of death and a lot of Defense
tech companies get stuck in this Valley
of Death Megan Milam is anderol senior
vice president of government relations
and she explains it like this Valley of
Death it's like the period of time from
after you got a prototype or a
demonstration before you get production
and you know it's called the Valley of
Death because that's sort of that window
where most companies die that's that two
to three year spot where the department
is kind of chipping through their
internal government processes you know
companies need to continue to show
revenue and growth and so if you do a
prototype or you do a demonstration and
it works really well the sort of
bureaucratic process is great we'll get
back to you in two three or four years
when we've done all of these next steps
they'll be ready to pick back up the
conversation and most companies can't
afford to kind of chip through that
Valley of Death so when you kind of look
at it from end to end from requirements
to programming to budgeting authorizing
the money appropriating the money
running an acquisition competition
fighting through protests picking the
winner you know in many cases this
process has become elongated from one
end of the other to about 10 years if
not more so if you imagine sort of
people right now sitting in the Pentagon
trying to define the specific
requirements for technology that they
believe they're going to need in 2033
that doesn't always work out that well
the end goal is to win what's called a
program of record this is when the
government has allocated ongoing funding
across many years to really put a new
piece of technology into use if you're
not winning these multi-billion dollar
programs of record you're just another
company that's kind of building you know
a cog in the machine gizmos and gadgets
that get a little bit of the government
small business money if you can't win a
major program of record it shows you
haven't changed the we did DOD things
you haven't changed the way the
procurement works if all the programs of
record are held by the Legacy primes
nothing will ever change foreign
but winning a big contract with the
Department of Defense wouldn't be easy
Andrew also brought on Chris Bros as
Chief strategy officer to help sell to
the government he was an expert in the
National Defense sector and had worked
with Senator John McCain for years most
of defense's very input focused very
process oriented we don't start with the
question of how do I generate air
dominance for example we tend to start
with the question of how do I build a
new generation of the same fighter
aircraft that I had before when I think
of disruption it's really focused on
what outcome are you trying to
accomplish so you know a commercial
analogy would be I want to be able to
move around town I want rides
I don't necessarily need a better
version of a taxi cab
I need an ability to get a ride quickly
cheaply safely when I need it where I
need it the way in which that capability
is delivered kind of doesn't matter to
me so the team honed in on a general
product strategy that holds to this day
interroll CEO explained to me like this
the formula for for building the right
things is is normally pretty
straightforward one we have to know
there is an urgent problem right so like
there has to be a sufficient level of
urgency around solving the problem two
we have to believe there is a technology
Edge we have we have to have some
insight into the problem of why we think
we can do this better over the long run
and it's something that has to be
solvable in a relatively quick time
frame this can't be 10-year research
projects that are only going to pay out
in 2030 or something like that this has
to be things that we think this is
solvable today and we could bring a
solution to field very very quickly it's
a risky Gambit because if the government
winds up not buying what they've built
anderol basically has to shelve the
project like what happened with the
firefighting tank but if it works they
will be the only company with a truly
effective product at the exact right
moment we're going to ship as fast as
possible it's not going to be done it's
not going to be perfect it's not gonna
be pretty but we're gonna get out there
and we're going to learn from the real
people who use this what needs to change
because they're the ones who actually
understand not the bureaucrats we're not
saying Hey give us a million this year a
million the next year a million the next
year in five years we'll have something
we can test we're saying you know what
we're just gonna spend 10 million
dollars of our own money over the next
six months we're gonna build it
ourselves and then we're gonna prove to
you that this can be done in six months
not six years and this is basically the
secret sauce that makes Andrew work even
though they are an independent company
they are able to identify the needs of
the military and go and actually build
complete systems before they are needed
the challenge of that is Department
defense is not actually structured or
equipped to buy capability in that way
it's just not how they do it and so
there's a lot of work that has to be
done still to actually convince DOD that
this is a business model that they can
wrap their heads around so for us
success very much was we need to go
toe-to-toe with the primes we're going
to be the next major defense Prime and
we are going to win major Perkins record
to be clear we thought that was going to
take five years minimum maybe seven
years we ended up doing it in less than
three by mid-2018 the team had grown to
30 people and the defense department was
starting to take notice things had been
going well with the sensor Towers but
Andrew wasn't really fulfilling their
original mission for that Andrew would
need to build entirely new systems and
essentially level up every aspect of the
business you can't just have one product
and one really big program office that
you're being responsive to we have like
multiple shots on goal that each have
these huge multi-billion dollar programs
associated with them Andrew built a
helicopter drone named ghost they also
built a counter drone system called
Anvil that could knock enemy drains out
of the sky automatically you can kind of
think about it as multi-service like Air
Force Navy Marine Corps Army as well as
multi-domain so things that fly things
that you're driving on the ground things
on the surface of the ocean things under
the surface of the ocean and space and
they were still adding features to their
lattice system to tie everything
together information from the sensor
Towers drones and other assets could now
all be synced together to create a clear
picture for the soldier on the front
lines the team had been working since
day one to get people to wake up to the
idea that the military was going to go
through a major shift and it was finally
working this small Tech startup building
camera towers for Border Patrol was
about to get a lot more important and
not a moment too soon
in early 2022 Andrew landed a one
billion dollar contract with Special
Operations Command to deliver counter
drone systems it was a big deal it
proved that the model worked and then
the unthinkable happened
Russia's full-scale invasion of Ukraine
as troops move in right now there are
reports of explosions in several cities
Mr Putin urged Ukrainian troops to lay
down their arms and go home Ukrainian
troops are watching and waiting saying
they are preparing for a fight President
Putin is warning any foreign attempt to
interfere with Russian action would lead
to quote consequences they have never
seen U.S President Joe Biden has
announced a new package of military aid
for Ukraine Putin chose this war
and now he and his country will bear the
consequences
[Music]
the war marked a Resurgence of great
power competition Russia was waging a
land war in Europe an unthinkable
Prospect in the Years following the end
of the Cold War the conflict was a
testament to the transformative power of
modern technology on the battlefield
crane has been a great example of how
the ubiquity
information of sensors has allowed them
to more effectively close kill Chains
It's actually a real problem how do you
set up a sensor system for air defenses
that is identifying not every bird as an
incoming drone zelenski actually reached
out to me back shortly after he was
elected years before this because he
read a Wired Magazine article about the
work we were doing with U.S border
Patrol and he said hey I've got a border
security problem it's called Russia now
remember Andrew was built with the goal
of avoiding these kinds of conflicts so
they were in a good position to help out
we've actually been involved in the
Ukraine war since the second week of the
conflict and I was actually there to
deliver some more hardware and also
train a bunch of Ukrainian Army
operators on how to how to best use it
to go after the Russians but there were
still many challenges ahead tearing the
skies above Ukraine cities swarmed kind
of coffee throwing underneath Spike
Cleveland Ukraine says it's ramping up
the Homegrown production of drones as it
struggled to cope with the demand for
the technology on the front line both
sides have been deploying drones in
significant numbers and on Monday
Ukraine was attacked now Russia has been
targeted military and even commercial
drones for surveillance and
reconnaissance missions we're seeing a
transformation of War as we've known it
and the future of war is one where
drones play a key role in this we've
seen a real evolution in terms of how
drones have been used over the course of
this conflict this may be the moment
where War really does become something
else but we're starting to get signal
from customers that this was an area
that they had concerns and they had
needs this is where they really expand
their strategy so instead of just
building everything internally like most
companies would do and like they were
doing in the early days they start
acquiring companies they bought a
company that makes a drone called the
Altius which is a longer range drone
that could actually act as a loitering
munition it can be launched from a
helicopter or submarine or the back of a
truck and it's really versatile the main
use case folks want to use it for is
anti-tank anti-armor Warfare our goal is
to precisely disable tanks that are you
know an invading forces is coming at you
with this is Mike Mattis the senior
director of usn strategy at anderol and
this is what he had to say I look at the
Ukraine I think honestly I'm looking at
prehistoric drone Warfare the rise of
cheap swarming drones has created a big
problem for the world's biggest
militaries you've got adversary
countries who can build drones really
really quickly you know they don't have
100 Years of Defense procurement slowing
them down right they're just their
military is moving as fast as they can
and that was part of the reason we
decided to go after it because we said
this is a unique situation where the
traditional purchasing model where
you're going to purchase two years in
advance or five years before it has to
be deployed will never work it turns out
that having air dominance is super
important
not only for the delivery of lethal
payloads but also for spotting or
intelligent surveillance and
reconnaissance and the United States
over the last 50 years has gotten used
to this world in which we have assumed
Complete Air dominance and so we haven't
historically had to worry about like
well you know if we send this plane up
is it going to come home drones will
need to evolve to become even more
versatile stealthy and capable of
operating in contested environments so
what role will anderol play going
forward
foreign
's Founders understand something very
important software is eating the
battlefield what you're seeing in
Ukraine is every unit has multiple very
small drones that can be used for
surveillance and reconnaissance and
targeting that's then guiding all of
these Legacy systems that were never
designed with that type of you know
operation in mind but it's nonetheless
extremely effective
so in order to be a successful defense
company in the 21st century you also
need to be a successful software company
they're all going to be networked
they're all going to have the ability to
collaborate to find Targets and engage
targets they're all going to have the
ability to like send them in when I kind
of know what's going on and be able to
decide at the last minute what I want to
do like that is how weapons will work in
the future you want the Commander in the
field to just like pull out hit the
phone or the tablet and then be like
like draw a circle here and be like
Patrol you know put drone asset on
patrol here you know alert me when you
find my target vehicle send put the
phone away go back to like like that
does not exist lattice is really built
to enable that kind of future fight
where a commander has understanding
information Advantage they're able to
make a decision to Marshall and sequence
the forces to gain force overmatch and
that is in essence enabled them decision
advantage that's how do I take advantage
of you know modern
machine learning techniques modern
software networking to be able to make
these things wildly more effective than
they were historically from a software
perspective you know what we're doing is
automating a problem that desperately
requires automation putting a human
being on the loop rather than putting so
many human beings in the loop that they
can never make decisions in a
time-intensive way and fundamentally
sort of means that they're operating at
greater risk it Harkens to a future
where a software first orientation is
necessary for a future fight and so
lattice is really designed to be a
battle management Aid that allows
operators to remove themselves from
being in the middle of all these things
and now that they're on the loop there's
this worry I think
culture that AI is going to spawn these
Terminators and while I think there is
reason to be cautious I do think it's
important we don't engage in hyperbole
we're not making Skynet here and we're
not making the Terminator here the idea
is that the authorities still reside
with somebody who has the permission to
do those things but the speed of the
fight is such that I can't allow the fog
and friction of all of this information
creating cognitive overload on an
operator or a bunch of operators
Hardware is going to change the sensors
are going to change the platforms are
going to evolve but it's the software at
the base level of doing all of that
autonomy to orchestrate all the sensors
the platforms the different weapon
systems that we're bringing together
we're not trying to make like the
world's most Exquisite radar we're
trying to make a cheap super effective
software-defined system fundamentally
with the ability to make all these
autonomous systems more powerful
[Music]
thank you Xi Jinping has been
stockpiling military equipment since he
took power in 2012 and the Taiwan
invasion is far from Unthinkable now if
you look at the last few decades we went
from being a bipolar World during the
Cold War revisit two superpowers to a
unipolar world it's the United States
and our you know our partners and
friends all around the world technology
has allowed a handful of players to
start making this a multi-polar world
again unipolarity of the world is being
challenged by the rise of China the U.S
and a lot of other countries I think
making bad foreign policy decisions that
allowed them to achieve unprecedented
economic power particularly in the area
of Technology they've allowed us to make
them ours very dependent on them for
technology and they've enabled
themselves to become very powerful using
technology Xi Jinping also wants to flex
China's military muscles as well this is
a rival that is building capability with
purpose you kind of look a bit more
closely you see them actually talking
about wanting to to use these types of
capabilities to fight differently XI
jinping's Relentless pursuit of
nationalistic goals has ignited a powder
keg of tension in the Taiwan Strait now
everyone is worried that this new era of
great power competition could lead to a
catastrophic clash between China and
Taiwan China has really always seen
itself as the preeminent organization in
the world that's why they consider
themselves the Middle Kingdom you have
Heaven you have Earth and you have China
as the Middle Kingdom and they see
themselves having been supplanted in the
last 150 years really by the West
the United States indo-pacific command
or Indo paycom as it's known is vastly
different from the border between Russia
and Ukraine it stretches from the west
coast of the United States all the way
to the Western border of India it's
essentially one massive ocean that
includes some of the world's most vital
shipping lanes economic powerhouses and
potential hot spots for conflict like
the Taiwan Strait the vast distances and
the importance of Naval and air power
changed the dynamic entirely today China
is one of a few countries that have
achieved the nuclear Triad they have the
ability to launch nuclear missiles from
Land Air and sea
when you're really kind of looking
closely at the types of Technologies the
types of capabilities that the Chinese
government in particular have been
feeling just a massive complex of
ballistic missiles cruise missiles all
focused on going after specific U.S
platforms and capabilities China's
missile capabilities pose huge threats
to the U.S Navy and the Pacific and U.S
allies in the asia-pacific region and so
does its Navy I think it's important to
understand let's talk shipbuilding
capacity today we simply don't have
enough ship building capacity to recover
from likely losses in a fight if China
was to lose half of their Navy today it
would take them two to three years to
rebuild their surface Navy if we were to
lose half of our surface Navy it would
take us probably 20 years to rebuild our
surface Navy we're never going to have
enough ships to actually get where we
need to go if we end up in a real
conflict with China
conflict has seemed inevitable if you've
been paying attention but it's only
recently that this is turned into front
page news so now the American Military
is starting to think that if these great
power conflicts are going to happen we
need the best technology possible the
only problem is that the big defense
primes haven't really been building the
technology that we need we always were
generating military technology that was
Superior to our closest competitor that
whole world is gone we are now in a peer
competition you know with China that has
military parity technological parity in
many cases with the United States the
consequences of going slowly are now
very acute when people get out of line
we've been able to Corral that redirect
that through a combination of military
force economic sanctions and diplomatic
right it's always going to be those
three things the US falling behind on
Military the U.S having an equal on this
will change the game substantially we're
moving towards a world where it's
becoming easier and easier for people to
become a power that threatens the United
States for the first time it's not clear
that the us and our friends have the
ability to stop these actors from doing
what they want
the Andrew team was well aware of this
though they were completely tapped into
what was happening geopolitically and so
the mission of the company was to fix
the American Military and fix the
defense technology industry before
something bad happened at Andrew we're
trying to build products that are
relevant to the Indo paycom aor in the
Pacific the ranges are significantly
longer than for example the war that's
going on in the Ukraine right now with
Russia and so when we do wargaming
thinking about what products Andrew
needs to develop in support of an
indo-paycom fight the F-35 is I think in
the realm of something that an anderol
could do especially once it's not a
human pilot system because it becomes
much easier to manufacture you don't
need such high redundancy you don't need
life support systems if you make
aircraft 10 times cheaper by accepting a
one percent failure rate in your initial
few flights that's actually totally fine
could you have a drone swarm big enough
smart enough effective enough lethal
enough to defend Taiwan for example from
an amphibious Invasion From China
something that Xi Jinping has said that
he intends to be able to do to seize
Taiwan there's a kind of a slate of
modern technology that needs to be
incorporated in our defense industrial
base that emphasizes Mass over Exquisite
systems that emphasizes autonomy those
capability sets are also the same
capability sets we've developed for
these some smaller scale systems but
deployed on different systems in
different ways in the future fight what
is going to be our advantage look
China's catching up to us on Hardware
it's getting commodified they have we
have the F-35 they have the j-20 what's
going to win it's the ability of this to
talk to each other and do unexpected
things and I think about this as
decision Advantage how do we give
decision advantage that's how we're
going to win
the United States has been strengthening
its alliances and Partnerships in the
indo-pacific for years now a prime
example of this strategy is the
partnership between America and
Australia the Australians have over the
last few years announced a huge ramp up
in their spending and in their kind of
changing of their strategy the Defense
Force we're told is quote not fit for
purpose if we were to be in a conflict
with the Chinese for example you've got
serious weaknesses in our ability to
prevent Chinese aggression in the
Pacific Australia is now preparing for a
war in order to avoid it our military
isn't able to operate independently
without a whole lot of stuff from the
Americans Even in our near region based
upon today's talks we will increase
rotational presence of U.S forces in
Australia U.S engagement in the
indo-pacific
makes an indispensable contribution the
two Nations have worked together to
bolster their military capabilities
conduct joint exercises and share
intelligence recently the United States
Australia and the United Kingdom
announced a new defense partnership
called akis which focuses on sharing
advanced technology including nuclear
power submarines to counter potential
threats in the indo-pacific under this
deal Australia will be buying five
nuclear-powered submarines from the U.S
caucus has won overriding objective to
enhance the stability of indo-pacific
amid rapidly shifting Global Dynamics
the orcas agreement we confirm here in
San Diego
represents the biggest single investment
in Australia's defense capability in all
of our history we are witnessing the
biggest conventional military buildup
that we have seen since the end of the
second world war this is a reaction to
what Chinese have been building what
they've been modernizing and then how
they've been using over the past two
decades Beijing said today that the
United States the United Kingdom and
Australia had embarked on a quote
dangerous path Arcus will transfer large
amounts of weapons-grade Highly enriched
uranium from nuclear states to a
non-nuclear state it risks nuclear
proliferation and violates the aims of
the non-proliferation treaty the
Anglo-Saxon world with the creation of
structures like orcas and with the
advancement of NATO military
infrastructure into Asia is making a
serious bet on many years of
Confrontation the submarine is the
ultimate apex predator today submarines
are important and challenging the
importance of the underwater domain is
one it's one of the few domains you can
still operate undetected which makes
autonomy important by the way you don't
want to come up to the surface you can't
communicate with submarines very well
they have to be smart enough to change
and alter and perform their mission
without continuous human guidance and
it's one of the few ways where we can go
to places where not supposed to be we
can listen to people we can follow
people we can interact with their
infrastructure we can make sure that
they're not interacting with our
infrastructure the underwater domain is
actually where some of the most
interesting stuff is happening everyone
talks about dog fights in the sky the
actually more interesting stuff is uh is
you know Hunt for Red October submarine
warfare the nuclear-powered submarines
are just one piece of the puzzle these
are incredibly expensive assets with
upwards of a hundred people on board
they're extremely important but we can't
use them for everything that's where
Andrew's dive program comes in we
acquired a company called Dive
Technologies a little over a year ago
dive when we acquired them was making
the dive LD the vision was always to
build an extra large version of that sub
after acquiring them we successfully
sold the Australian Navy this joint
development program based on kind of
this core IP we had with dive already
taking that and then supersizing it to
be clear we're going to have band
submarines for the foreseeable future
there's a lot of things we're only going
to do with them like I don't think we're
going to have autonomous nuclear
submarines driving around that have to
make a determination as to when they
should be destroying another country
that's one of like the very few niches
where I think people are very much going
to be the dominant the dominant system
the result will be an entirely new kind
of submarine that can be used in
completely different ways from the
nuclear sub dive at scale is in very
very interesting problem pretty
adversary number one you can definitely
find yourself a metallic object in
shallow water and with dive it's just
gonna be much more difficult right it's
largely not a metallic object it's
essentially 3D printed plastic if you
will with some you know batteries and
other things in there but ultimately
it's going to be have a much lower
signature electromagnetically
additionally it's going to be autonomous
which means I don't need to have a
manned submarine or a manned surface
ship nearby steering it at risk and so
from a deterrent standpoint in
incredibly capable uh platform
as Andrew shifted from a tiny startup
building sensor Towers to a serious
defense contractor with more than a
thousand employees they've been
confronted with some hard questions at
the end of the day these are weapons of
war we're talking about it's serious
business and shouldn't be taken lightly
is it ethically responsible to build
weapons of war that's the key question I
think there's sort of the debate of
whether you will or will not work on
weapons is probably the wrong debate I
think the question is you can make a
decision of
whether you want to participate in the
US's ability and the Allies ability to
defend themselves and you know kind of
use military force or the threat of
military force to accomplish political
ends right like that's fundamentally
what the military does I get into
debates with people all the time they
say oh well you know I you know Ukraine
has really changed my mind and now I
want to work in you know in defense and
I say well look that's great I'm glad
you've changed your mind like good for
you you know you know pat on the back
but it's way too late it's way too late
for you to change your mind on this
because at the end of the day you need
to get these people the weapons and the
tactics before The Invasion happens
humans have been debating this for
literally thousands of years and one of
the most robust Frameworks on the topic
is called just War Theory it was
pioneered by a 5th Century theologian
named Saint Augustine his goal was to
ensure that if we must fight we would
only do so for morally justifiable
reasons and with a sense of humanity he
broke his thinking into two key areas
the first first is the justification for
going to war and the second dealt with
proper conduct during war even though
just War theory is 100 years old it's
still used today it's the backbone of
many International laws such as the
Geneva conventions
so that's why anderol is so focused on
building defense technology that can
prevent Wars by focusing on systems that
keep troops safe and increase
Battlefield awareness they can hopefully
deter conflict before it starts we're
not trying to build the tools that go
into Wars that have already started we
need to prevent these things from
happening and we can only do it if we
build products that are so
overwhelmingly good that people feel
like they couldn't possibly win against
them
laughs anderol has been continually
evolving as a company since its start
back in 2017 and they've hit some
incredible milestones in that time but
the story is far from over though
they've built some great technology but
they are still a small company and still
have a lot of work to do geopolitical
tensions are still on the rise the China
Taiwan situation is very serious and the
Russia Ukraine situation is just getting
Crazier by the day Andrew needs to
continue to innovate and continue to
deliver technology that can keep the
world safe it's really important that we
don't end up in a hot War because it
would have a huge toll on the world
anderol
is still not a sure thing we've had like
three coin flips that were critical to
our company when I say a coin flip I
mean it was it was a bet that we made or
a contract we needed where it was 50 50
or Worse odds for us it truly could have
gone heads or tails who knows the good
news is now I think we're going to the
point where we have like a dozen coin
flips every year and it's hard to flip
tails uh 12 times in a row companies
fail through no fault of their own
sometimes there's been three coin flips
that went our way and I think back on
the company's history I say wow if those
contracts wouldn't have gone through our
company would look very different I get
told this all the time like you guys are
not just coming to us asking us to buy
your particular widget is it for a
government corporate welfare you were
actually coming to us with thoughtful
creative and innovative ideas and that
will make our national security stronger
I learned a ton from talking to the
Android team and I hope you enjoyed
learning about it too it's a really
fascinating company and I'm genuinely
excited about what they do I hope you
enjoyed this video And subscribe for the
next one thanks a lot
[Music]